[Music]
think about all the things that need to
happen for a human settlement to thrive
obtaining food building shelter raising
children and more there needs to be a
way to divide resources organize major
efforts and distribute labor efficiently
now imagine having to do this without
any sort of planning or higher level
communication welcome to the ant colony
ants have some of the most complex
social organization in the animal
kingdom living in structured colonies
containing different types of members
who perform specific roles but although
this may sound similar to some human
societies this organization doesn't
arise from any higher-level decisions
but is part of a biologically programmed
cycle in many species all the winget
males and winget Virgin Queens from all
the nearby colonies in the population
each leave from their different nests
and meet at a central place to mate
using pheromones to guide each other to
a breeding ground after mating the
male's die off while females try to
establish a new colony the few that are
successful settle down in a suitable
spot lose their wings and begin laying
eggs selectively fertilizing some using
stored sperm they've saved up from
mating fertilized eggs grow into female
workers who care for the Queen and her
eggs build and defend the colony and
forage for food while unfertilized eggs
grow into males whose only job is to
wait until they are ready to leave the
nest and reproduce beginning the cycle
again so how do worker ants decide what
to do and when well they don't really
although they have no methods of
intentional communication individual
ants do interact with one another
through touch sound and chemical signals
these stimuli accomplish many things
from serving as an alarm to other ants
if one is killed two signaling when a
queen is nearing the end of her
reproductive life but one of the most
impressive collective capabilities of an
ant colony is to thoroughly and
efficiently explore large areas without
any predetermined plan most species of
have little or no sense of sight and can
only smell things in their vicinity
combined with their lack of high-level
coordination this would seem to make
them terrible explorers but there is an
amazingly simple way that ants maximize
their searching efficiency by changing
their movement patterns based on
individual interactions when two ants
meet they sense each other by touching
antennae if there are many hints in a
small area this will happen more often
causing them to respond by moving in
more convoluted random paths in order to
search more thoroughly but in a larger
area with less ants where such meetings
happen less often they can walk in
straight lines to cover more ground
while exploring their environment in
this way an ant may come across any
number of things from threats or enemies
to alternate nesting sites and some
species have another capability known as
recruitment when one of these ants
happens to find food it will return with
it marking its path with a chemical
scent other ants will then follow this
pheromone trail renewing it each time
they manage to find food and return once
the food in that spot is depleted the
ants stop marking their return the scent
dissipates and ants are no longer
attracted to that path these seemingly
crude methods of search and retrieval
are in fact so useful that they are
applied in computer models to obtain
optimal solutions from decentralized
elements working randomly in exchanging
simple information this has many
theoretical and practical applications
from solving the famous Traveling
Salesman problem to scheduling computing
tasks and optimizing internet searches
to enabling groups of robots to search a
minefield or a burning building
collectively without any central control
but you can observe these fascinatingly
simple yet effective processes directly
through some simple experiments by
allowing ants to enter empty spaces of
various sizes and paying attention to
their behavior ants may not be able to
vote hold meetings or even make any
plans but we humans may still be able to
learn something from the way that such
simple creatures are able to function so
effectively in such complex ways
you
[Music]